i've lost respect for italians that that
are in america
wait what it's just such an amazing
place you'd have to be dumb to leave
wait which italians in america are you
talking about all italians that left
well when did they leave whenever they
did okay
dumb like mussolini even
yeah i'm done
what i'm saying you under mussolini's
dictatorship or whatever and you leave
you still got spaghetti they still got
cheap
we don't got spaghetti good weather you
can look at the coliseum like there's
tons of things you can do if you're a
jewish italian yeah you get the [ __ ] out
of there but if you're not what's the
big deal fight a little war go back to
the beach run it up amalfi you're not
gonna fight in august honestly it's too
hot
everybody takes august off like yeah you
gotta take vacation from war bro
yo if there's no italians in america
though there's no cool white people in
america yo yo yo that yeah it's
disrespectful yeah
it does
the only he got these nerds
italy though and just italians in
general and i'm sure that there is like
you know some leftover italy in the
italians that are here but like
even the italians that came here
they're coming before italy is the the
country that it is today right right
like italy is 1947
but it's a democracy yeah i think like
18
maybe 70 or something like that before
that that's like a republic it was a
republican i think so something like
that maybe it's basically it's under
like uh either a king or tyler dictator
etc yeah so it's like a it's it's a
younger country than america yeah it's
it's governmentally uh governmentally
culturally though yes but culturally
it's old very old thousands of years old
like outside of obviously the greek
empire we're talking about the west
obviously you know 5 000 years ago you
go to india you find these but just
we're talking about western civilization
and
you're in it and i went to i went to
venice and venice was like this
remarkably beautiful city but there's no
people there yeah and a city without
people is a museum i found the people in
venice to be unfriendly
i would too though because imagine you
lived in times square yeah um
you know what i mean it's like east town
the whole city is time square and it's
kind of sad because when you're there
you're like this is the most stunning
place i've ever seen yeah the entire it
doesn't even make sense you're like how
does every street end on water yeah like
it's so incredible and like but because
it's all tourists you lose some flavor
use some sauce like the beautiful thing
about new york is not seeing the [ __ ]
buildings and seeing some guy go you
know [ __ ] out of here like seeing
somebody cursing somebody seeing
somebody do something wild seeing a new
yorker actually be nice when you think
they're there it completes the city yes
for me a city is the people right and
the energy of the city is the people
and that informs everything else about
it yeah right and so venice was cool
florence was also like really cool but
again lots of tourists and again it's
summers tour season is the most
remarkable you know uh empire in history
the roman empire so you're still going
to want to visit these places right
but florence doesn't even get popping
until the 1500s yeah renaissance is
built kind of around florence right
rome though bro
son
rome is the most amazing city that's
ever existed and there will never be a
city as amazing ever again and i say
that as like a proud new yorker it is
the most amazing thing about rome at
least for me was that
all these ancient relics aren't behind
like a wall with a ticket together yeah
you are eating dinner and the pantheon
is right there right you're eating
dinner in a plaza that was built 2 000
years ago yeah you know what i'm saying
like yeah you're just having a drink and
there's a stone wall that existed
2 000 years ago yeah that was the edge
of the city everything that you're
seeing
yeah is just this amazing ancient
history that's right in front of your
face and i just got [ __ ] overwhelmed
by it and there's like two
like historic times in italy which in
most countries you go to there's like
one time yeah italy had the roman empire
which one of the craziest empires we've
seen in history one of them and then
they had the renaissance yeah so you see
[ __ ] from bc
and it's all historic and then there's
also all this historic [ __ ] from 1 500
a.d or whatever it is so it's like
history on top of history it's [ __ ]
crazy and they just like blend and bake
it all in like
even as you see like the influence of
catholicism and this is something i want
to talk to you guys about but like
italians are like the least catholic
people
you know i mean like my understanding of
catholicism because i come from you know
british roots right it's like very kind
of repressed and withheld
exactly like stiff upper lip uh
everything's about the afterlife dude
don't worry about this life yeah
the afterlife is going to be dope so
like suffer through this life and life
yes something suffer through this life
life is suffering but that's okay
because the afterlife's gonna be lit
italians whose culture exists before
catholicism
is about indulging in life
everything is about servicing the have
the best food yeah the ripest tomato
which comes from america by the way they
didn't have tomatoes before us isn't
that crazy that's enough yeah i did not
know that wow
they didn't have pasta and [ __ ] first
question is like are you gonna cap and
say they have better pizza yeah
stop it not like i'll just say japan had
better pizzas oh no i'm being i'm being
honest bro
how you ain't been nowhere no i haven't
no you don't you went to italy yes alex
traveled bro [ __ ] i traveled he don't
seem like that he he forgets everything
but he's been all around the world yeah
al who knows he's been when he's been
there again he goes
so so okay i'm glad that you guys and
you spent time there too yeah okay so
the the the culture is just built around
these amazing indulgences right it's
like getting the most out of life and
that was probably for the top point one
percent right yeah even when you look at
the renaissance we think like
everybody's just painting and existing
it's like no most people's lives were
[ __ ] miserable
suck they die in a [ __ ] dysentery but
the top one percent was living the most
lavish beautiful life that you could
ever imagine and obviously those are the
people that write the history books etc
but when you look at what these people
what the focus was right like love
passion family speaking with your hands
yelling screaming hugging kissing it is
the least when you think of like irish
catholic they're the least like catholic
people you can imagine right now
obviously catholicism is like baked into
the culture the [ __ ] vatican is right
there
but it gave me one a new perspective on
i guess catholicism because if this is
where it was birthed then this is a more
true form of it
potentially so now
i'm looking at that in a different way
but i'm also it gave me a crazy new
perspective on
uh on on soccer clubs
i didn't understand what
football as you guys say
was to europeans
right so
and now i kind of it makes sense because
when i was living in barcelona we would
like ask people from barcelona like like
hey are you a big fan of the team
they're like oh i love the team it would
be like who's on the team and these
[ __ ] wouldn't even know three
people on this team
and
it wasn't about the players it was about
the identity and then i started to learn
that these people
don't see themselves as italian first
they see themselves as neapolitan first
they see themselves as venetian first
right florentine that's where all those
italians are like oh i'm sicilian yes
like why are you saying this we don't
care we don't get it right because
america
for the most part is founded as america
yes there's the 13 colonies and we have
states rice and all this other [ __ ] but
for the most part we see each other as
one cohesive unit right once you're
america you're america yes right so it's
like and it's not like new york is
fighting against new jersey for some
[ __ ] and we've always been like
bickering where all these different
regions were under different rule at
different times yeah right so they were
fighting for their identity the
florentines were fighting for their
identity venetians are fighting for
their identity the sardinians are
fighting for their identity
so that's the last bastion of that
identity that still gets to fight right
right so now i understand the soccer
club what it means to someone from
munich because munich wasn't part of
germany always but it was munich yeah do
you know what i'm saying like these
areas existed as their own little
kingdoms yeah their own little townships
and they have their own identities and
then have agreed to be part of this
thing yeah but have existed for
thousands of [ __ ] years so now i see
football as this reflection of kind of
who they are yeah instead of oh i just
really like this team enough to fight
somebody about it it's like it's not
about sports it's about identity that's
it yeah and and i think as like a knicks
fan i'm not like the knicks represent
new york and it's like not like
dominance
things representing you exactly he was
here way before any of that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that and american
identity is assimilation it's a melting
pot you're going to come here you're
going to assimilate you might have your
influence but we're all going to be
american and i think maybe that's why we
get hyped about sports when it comes to
the olympics yes right because that's
the closest thing i guess exactly the
way we feel about olympics they'll feel
about soccer yes right we don't have to
be a fan of [ __ ] curling yeah but if
the us is doing it yeah and we're going
up against [ __ ] germany we're like
run it back you saw what happened
you'd start changing that [ __ ] i'm in
yeah i'm in i don't care i mean whatever
who we playing i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't know yeah what's the sport on i
don't know never seen it
usa it's just contagious you're in it
yeah and then there's india is a similar
thing where it's like we weren't always
india so all these different regions
different languages
yeah you know what i mean so it's i
understand that and i wonder how unique
the american this is our country thing
bro it's so unique because we were
forced into country so soon yeah whereas
these other places like people developed
they developed their own towns and they
were constantly like invaded yeah
invasion was part of life yeah you just
had the huns just coming up